cali c'est votre anniversaire et bien
j'en oublie on a beau cadeau pour vous
regarder
il s'agit d'un coffret séjour avec un
dîner en duo un soin relaxant
voilà pour vous un groupe oui mais comme
vous êtes joueuses ça vous l'avez mégane
vous pouvez peut-être choisir un autre
cadeau à bill justement c'est pour ça
qu'il est là aujourd'hui bill adil à
vous proposer
belle moon a mis ses huiles et mon amie
kelly
le principe est très simple vous avez
décroissent les croise sa tête va tomber
le principe est très simple civil de
vous proposer un cadeau attention le
dilemme est le suivant soit vous
conservez le gâteau ou ou le changer
contre un cadeau mystérieux
à vous de choisir alors vous allez
devoir faire un choix
sur le plateau il y a deux rideaux c'est
le cas des rideaux tu l'as bien rideau
bleu et le rouge le bleu c'est
mystérieux
selon lui c'est là où ça bouge vous
découvrez les missions vous non oui
c'est bien ce que je pensais merci
derrière chacun un cadeau
est-ce que vous gardez votre cadeau ou
est ce qu'on voulait l'échanger et si
oui contre quel rideau sachez qu'ils
vont avoir un cadeau bien mieux ou un
cadeau pire
kelly a qu'est-ce qu'on choisit alors
déjà je pense que j'ai choisir un des
leurs rideaux ah oui 3 le séjour non si
j'adore ouais mais j'ai très envie de
savoir ce qui se passe derrière et
joueuses à ios - mais avec ce choix
bousri baba est-ce que je peux avoir
l'avis des copains non à l'astre sur le
show nu que le choix du vélo qui a dit
vous savez au bac vous serez tout seul
regarde série dans les yeux regarder et
pose la question pour voir série
d'organisations ou rouge bleu rouge
je ne peux pas vous dire et habillés en
rouge aujourd'hui c'est un signe
peut-être peut-être comme tu as déjà de
là où je prends le bleu alors que vous
prenez
je vais prendre le
rouge et a déjà le séjour s'est terminé
on va voir aubry se cacher derrière le
rideau bleu
ah oui quel iv novelli vous êtes sûr que
le champ gauche au jeu ne sera pas le
bleu et à très vite moi c'est regarder
mois après à web pour voir ça peut être
toi tu as raison donc on base aux bleus
d'être sûr mais plus je sais bien kelly
poète accueil il a derrière le bleu il y
avait des toilettes mais qui ont été
faites par un garçon je vous donner son
nom tout à l'heure avec votre portrait
sur la clé way est mon portrait avait
souvent des problèmes un peu voilà vous
passez à côté ou pas été regardée comme
idée vous avez regardé assez moche
arrivé et vous savez que remettre du
tourniquet allemand de tous les
chroniqueurs regarder la seconde il
amusé c'est bien quand même un bon sens
capter quoi à ces jeux d'hiver ça et
ouais ça te sens pas comme on va sa
salle ça s'est perdu la vingtième heure
merci on voit que vous connaissez alors
elle pour sookie le bol ça ils auront
lieu en rien une fois qu'on a fait ça va
ou après ça reste on comptait pas la
balle aux épaules med mais quel abruti
kelly vous prenez le rideau rouge où
vous gardez votre cadeau un peu trop
tard regarde sa tête
voilà qui est dit
vous avez choisi le rideau rouge
joël carpet
non c'est le mot qui me tient à coeur
c'est possible demain je vais compter
jusqu'à est ce que vous pouvez regarder
à l'intérieur ils me regardent et après
4 minutes on va arrêter avec ce petit
jeu c'est le mec qui va sur les toits tu
fais la toon par sa tête
ah mais oui c'est vrai qu'avec matthieu
delormeau qui est innovant joue un mec
qui me fait qu'ils courent
ohlala sa tête est celle où quoi
alors ça te plairait le rideau rouge ou
le séjour
mais s'est vu doubler moustérienne route
el bouaghi saturés d'eau rouge rideau
rouge rideau rouge
oui le rouge oui c'est sûr mais oui à
cet égard dès maintenant regardera les
sourires la coupe de tunisie
alors oui mais le para sinon un
narbonnais vont alors voilà je prends le
rideau allait vous faut pas les voir
calé
[Applaudissements]
c'est court
kachine
[Applaudissements]
c'est sympa à regarder sarion ah mais
oui je suis content vous